os outros objetos mais um vídeo eu estou
aqui foram ensinar como fazer um mangual
que esta arma ak medieval potter
espinhos ou então não
mas eu gosto mais desta versão que das
11 horas imagem diabólico
aí foi só fazer isso porque o gabriel do
canal do mastro invenções me desafiou
então eu vou deixar o link do canal de
uma descrição do vídeo e agora vamos
começar o tutorial posso passo então
bora lá
a primeira coisa que vocês vão ter que
fazer é imprimir esse tempo porque vocês
vão encontrar na minha página do
facebook a partir das fotografias podem
constar na descrição do vídeo mas tem
que cortar esta parte das bolas e lá no
pedaço do popular ou se usaram um pouco
compacto mas se vocês quiserem podem
usar que o popular um dos caixas normais
dos produtos pois vocês têm custado
estudo com muito cuidado e se vocês
forem crianças peçam ajuda um adulto é
muito importante que vocês não façam em
cima da vossa mesa arranja um pedaço de
madeira que vocês possam chegar e corta
em cima disso vou precisar de três
pecinhas destas ou então mais só se
usarem a população das caixas e o
conselho que vocês passam 15 então sei
porque ela é muito mais frágil em
comparação com esse que eu estou
utilizado depois é o mesmo processo
vocês com muito cuidado tem que executar
tudo à volta destas pessoas vão fazer a
conexão entre a bola ea correta omã copa
quando terminar de cortar as partes têm
que juntar utilizando cola e usei como
quinto mas se vocês quiserem podem usar
como ipva que também serve a linha tudo
muito bem
deixem ficar tem que cobrar estas parte
pela linha e se vocês quiserem que seja
mais fácil podem usar uma régua ou então
fazendo a borda da mesa
e é muito importante que você dobra em
extremos aqui também foi juntar isto
cruzei com li qing isso vocês não
tiverem o documento que vocês cumpram
uma pistola de cola quente destas porque
não é muito caro e ajuda bastante a
agilizar o trabalho
por que usar uma cola que demora um
minuto minuto e maya ficar
imaginem vocês têm ficar assegurar cada
parte o minuto a minuto e mãe
agora com a pistola de cola quente vocês
têm ficaram as pedras 20 segundos 20
segundos e mais para frente vamos fazer
mais coisas utilizando modos assim desta
maneira em população
e vejo que junta as duas partes formando
uma bola e isso aqui é bastante
resistente mesmo claro também vai
entender um pouco do pão com vocês
usarem o e agora esta parte que conecta
a bola e mais tarde
a korin e fazer o cabelo eu vou juntar
três folhas com o tamanho a3
agora se vocês não tiverem essas folhas
grandes não tem problema nenhum vocês
podem juntar duas folhas a4 e assim
dessa maneira é bom ter uma folha com o
tamanho a3
ou seja neste caso vamos usar vez a
escolha a 3 para fazer aquela parte
grande
isso ocorre todos os anos aqui e não foi
atrás e vai rolar este papel que grande
à volta dessa rixa
isso vai fazer um carro bastante
resistente para fechar vou usar que cola
pva por usar fita vai notar-se pois na
hora da pintura dobra eu fui atrás da
mãe depois um pouco de tv a procurar uma
parte a outra com cola na borda da folha
e envolvem assim a volta para dar um
livro para vocês vão à guerra tem que
fazer agora uma parte ficou mais ou
menos 3 cm
simplesmente isso é o olho deve ser
muito certo até que vocês façam assim
aquela bolinha ou espanhola e dobre para
dentro pra ficar assim mais perfeito e
vamos lutar esta parte na outra
extremidade do cabo
adoro ver que cola quente podem usar tva
também é importante usar em cola para
não se ver pois na hora da pintura
agora vou pôr na outra extremidade
aí eu disse isto me dá pena mas pronto é
é uma partida feminina numa extremidade
e outra parte na outra extremidade e
vocês vendo esta é a imagem que consegue
perceber facilmente como é que vocês têm
que fazer mas o que me deixou falar do
papel para ficar com essa aparência
agora vamos fazer uns detalhes na parte
de agarrar para dar a ideia que é cor
então eu fiz aqui uma faixa bem
pequenina com mais ou menos assim a
volta para vocês podem fazer um padrão
se vocês quiserem fazer que com com
faixas cruzadas ou é que não está murai
que você encontra tutoriais na internet
como fazer uma coisa bastante simples
para começar mas pra frente quem sabe
faz uma coisa mais complexa depois
confessa as faixas de cinco meninas só
para tapar é onde começa e onde acaba
vai ficar mais bonito que daqui uns
detalhes para dar a impressão que é a
madeira
assim passam de cola quente por cima e
acho bonito efeito
vou colocar aqui um pouco de cola quente
nesta extremidade da impressão que é
natal soltado lá e agora vou fazer a
corrente que é bastante simples vocês
têm que usar uma folha com o tamanho a4
ou seja o curta é uma folha com tamanho
a3 ou mãe ou seja uma folha de tamanho
a4 na extremidade
depois é só ir lá e colar desta maneira
eu já fiz corrente em dois outros
projetos que o processo era idêntico
simples e este concorrente também é
bastante resistente vocês podem
experimentar já pendurei dois garrafões
de cinco litros uma correntista e guento
e eu fiz isso num no vídeo de kunar e
dos corpos
agora vou fazer aqui uma conexão para
juntar a bola aquela parte do carro já
que é só uma rifa é bastante simples
vejam que eu não ando eu fiz assim em
linha reta
a lei fala em uma espécie de triângulo
em caixa fora metem em cola e até o
final se vocês quiserem fazer de ângulos
em outro tempo vai tomar que vocês vão
ter que imprime variam dependendo da
quantidade teríamos que vocês quiserem
utilizar e fazer em cima da população
como vocês viram anteriormente e também
tem lá um template concordo se vocês
quiserem usar contra e tenham cuidado
porque tem as partes assim bicudos então
não andei a bater uns nos outros com
isso aí
acho que estão sim você tem que segurar
até o século
agora vocês podem falar e também na bola
ou então podem fazer isso que estou
fazer que misturam cola pva com água
mesmo um pouco mais pva do que eu tinha
aqui é porque um ficou demasiado aguarda
neste vídeo você tem pois usa jornal
para pôr a volta ou então podem usar
papel higiênico que é mais fácil com
papel higiênico só como eu tinha vários
jornais de usar só jornal
em cobrir o triângulo e deixar ficar eu
sei que 25 triângulos destes
agora vou cobrir a bola cruzar a equipe
do cinema do jornal e outra vez aquela
mistura de ipva com água
é só vocês verem pondo fim a volta e
esse papel vai reforçar as conexões e
fiz só uma camada de jornal
mas se vocês quiserem podem pôr mais
queimadas e sei que é um produto que as
pessoas passam pois como [ __ ] e ele
disfarça bastante bem é nas conexões e
eu não sei como é que são os produtos se
vocês souberem deixem nos comentários
porque eu gostava de pôr algum produto
pode passar com lixo e vai ficar assim
mais perfeita imagem domingo eo e
colocar esse cola volta dos triângulos
para dar ideia que nós temos foram
soltados na bola também vai ficar mais
resistente desta maneira vou passar uma
camada de cola tv para ser mais fácil
pois pintar e ficar melhor
o acabamento cola cola e tinta branca
com tinta presa e passará assim a
primeira camada no momento em que eu
faço é pinto como a costura e depois né
seguida pinto como cor mais clara e oi
fica bastante bonito agora no início
como podem ver se me faz e se vocês
quiserem para realizar o trabalho podem
usar um secador
tentei extremidade usando preto também e
é parte do quero que pareça que é
mutável e estou usando agora uma tinta
que é do ouro pintura ti por aí pontuar
agora o cabo para a ideia que curto e
castanho vai mostrar o quinto ouro com o
escuro para fazer aqui para o que eu
quero que as pessoas pensem queima da
droga até agora está muito frio mas
talvez agora de ensinar e segunda cor em
todas as partes vai ficar muito mais
bonito vai vim aqui para dar o time da
madeira e até se parece uma coisa má
imagem
assim hoje eu vou dar aqui uma esponja é
algo que vocês podem usar aquela esponja
de cozinha normalmente corta um cursinho
e consegue fazer a mesma coisa
isso não é nada mais do que um docente
cuja num pedacinho de um pauzinho quer
usar em tintas é muito importante que
vocês usem máscara de proteção sempre
que só com um
esta fita para pintor etapas para que
vocês não querem sujar dar uns toques
indicações de longe não façam de perto a
cair longe assim só uns toques gente é e
fica logo o efeito total e na frente
também na corrente e na boa
e eu ainda usar um pouco o preto que
ficou demasiado prateado então percebem
que acontece então por josé sócrates a
não ter um varão clientes para e preta
aí eu não estou bastante satisfeito com
o resultado final e vou fazer umas
coisas do gênero
agora é que estão os dois modelos o da
esquerda e fez o primeiro e depois com
os pneus eu fiz
o tutorial e pronto só chegamos sofia
muito obrigado steve e eu espero que
tenham gostado do projeto do novo design
do canal que deu algum trabalho fazer
mas acho que o resultado final valeu a
pena é tão isso muito obrigado até a
próxima